PROFESSOR: So while
I've argued that there
are many ways in which
a room can become
well mixed,
hopefully well enough
to apply our well
mixed criterion
for airborne transmission
through long range aerosols,
there is one very important
way in which the transmission
problem is never well mixed.
And that is taking
into account the source
of the particles,
which is the exhaling
of an infected
individual which leads
to a very high concentration
of particles leaving
the mouth, which then
ends up being dispersed
throughout the room.
And there is a sort of
space and time dependence
of that process which
we must consider
in looking at other
possibilities of transmission
than just the well
mixed background air.
So in particular,
I've already indicated
that the flows
generated by breathing
tend to be at higher
enough Reynolds number
to generate turbulence.
And in particular, they generate
a turbulent jet which ends up
taking the form of a cone.
Not perfectly but
approximately a cone,
which means that the
radius of the jet
is alpha times the
position of the jet here.
So if I write a
coordinate system,
a cylindrical
coordinate system where
z is the direction of the flow
and r is the radial coordinate,
then that's the cone and
the cone angle is alpha.
The term alpha also has
a physical interpretation
as the air entrainment
coefficient.
And for respiratory
jets in the air,
this coefficient is
usually around 0.1 to 0.15.
So that gives you basically
the opening angle of the cone.
So I will come to
explaining and deriving
why the jet has the
shape of a cone.
But let's just assume that.
And let's continue
with the assumption
that the flow is at high
Reynolds number which
means it's dominated by
inertia, by kinetic energy,
and by the tendency
for the fluid
to keep wanting to move
in a new direction.
Now if the fluid
coming out of the mouth
were just being spit
out at a very high rate,
you might imagine a very
narrow kind of stream of air.
But the reason it's widening
is that air is actually
being entrained, is that
some of the ambient air
is being sucked in.
And this is making the jet
have more and more fluid in it.
But then that fluid is
sharing the momentum.
It's also spreading and
diffusing the particles.
And the wider it
gets, the more it
slows down because
now that momentum
is being shared through the sort
of turbulent exchange going on.
So let's do that calculation.
So we have-- so just
remind you that we
are in a situation of very
high Reynolds number typically.
And we will assume
that there is roughly--
and it's actually
a good assumption--
roughly a constant
momentum flux.
What that means if
I take a slice here
and I look at, essentially,
the kinetic energy
density or the
momentum per time that
is crossing a slice of the
jet, that that actually
should be conserved.
And so if I write that
momentum flux as capital K
is the area of the
cross section pi
r^2, if I look at
a given position r here.
And then I have the
momentum is the density
of the fluid, which
is the air, times
the velocity field,
the velocity.
And so that's momentum.
Momentum flux would be
momentum times velocity or rho
v^2, which is also
kinetic energy density.
This quantity should
be roughly constant.
So we can now solve for
the average velocity,
v bar, which would be square
root of K over pi rho_a times
1/r, after we
take the square root,
but then because
we have a cone r
is alpha z So this
is square root of K
over pi a 1 over alpha z.
So we can see the velocity is
decaying like 1 over distance
from the mouth.
So the jet is slowing down.
But it's still, of course,
continued to advance
as the momentum is being shared
across a larger and larger area
of entrained, turbulent flow.
So we can now use this
result to figure out
what is the rate of
progress of the front.
So if I call this
z of the front,
so let's say when I
first start exhaling
it is kind of a wall
of droplets and I
can sketch that this flow
is actually full of droplets
that we're interested
in tracking,
I'd like to know how those
are first leaving the mouth.
Well, I can write
that this velocity is,
at a given position
corresponding to the front,
is dzf dt.
And if this is the f, so
I apply this at the front,
then I can put the zf on the
other side and I have zf dzf dt
is equal to square root
of K over pi rho_a.
Then I've got, I guess also,
an alpha or 1 over alpha.
And then this
expression here can
be written as 1/2 times the
derivative of zf squared.
So I can then solve for the
position of the front and I
find zf is equal to--
well, let's see what I get.
I put the 2 on the other side.
I take a square root.
So I get 2 over alpha to the
1/2, I get K over pi rho_a
was a square root.
And then I take another
square root so I get a 1/4.
And then I get t to the 1/2.
Because when I
integrate this equation,
I get zf squared is all this
stuff times t, starting from t
equals 0.
So we find is that, initially,
the jet starts to progress
like square root of time.
And so this coefficient
here is some kind of--
has the units of a diffusivity.
So it kind of like appears that
the jet is sort of diffusing.
You could call this
D_effective,
sort of for the
front of the jet.
But that doesn't last
forever because some
point the person
closes their mouth
and starts breathing in again,
and maybe pulls the fluid
back a little bit.
But not too much.
Because it has momentum and
it keeps moving forward.
So when somebody breathes, it
starts out looking like that.
But then at a later time if I
draw this same person again,
then--
in fact, actually, let me
draw him with a closed mouth.
Because he's just
finished, let's say,
exhaling is getting ready
for his next breath.
So now this blob of fluid has
kind of worked its way out
and it's now somewhere out here.
And this is what we call a puff.
So if you're smoking,
for example, a cigarette
you know that you can
create a puff of smoke
by just releasing a
finite amount of fluid.
And then it kind
of goes out and it
makes some interesting
patterns and usually
is very turbulent unless
you're very careful in trying
to control it.
And of course this contains
lots of these droplets
that we're interested in.
And so then now we
can briefly ask,
how fast does the puff move.
Well, you see here,
the fluid keeps
moving because it's constantly
being given momentum.
So if it's a steady jet
as you're breathing,
you're pushing, pushing,
pushing and so this thing
keeps moving on the square root
of t, it keeps entraining more.
But as soon as you stop
giving it more momentum,
you give it just a finite
amount of momentum,
then the puff
actually slows down.
It doesn't keep pushing
ahead as quickly.
It also doesn't entrain
more air as quickly either.
And we can do a
very simple argument
to see what happens
to the scaling.
So this momentum flux here
was a constant momentum flux
in the case of a jet.
But here in the
case of a puff, we
could, maybe as a
very crude estimate,
just say that the momentum
flux is something now replaced
by some kind of constant
value that is maintained only
for a time, tb, which is
the time of the breath,
and then averaged over
a longer period times.
If you think of this as kind of
like an average momentum flux,
we've injected some momentum
flux but then we took it away.
And so if I want to find out the
average over a period of time t
I have to divide by t.
So you see if I do that then,
I arrive that in the puff case
that the position of
the front or the puff
is a lot of these
same constants here,
but is now scaling as t to the
1/4 because my K has a 1 over t
and it's raised to 1/4
power, then I end up
with zf goes like t to 1/4.
So it slows down.
So first it was sort
of square root of time.
Now it's become more
[INAUDIBLE] time.
And it's almost just
sort of sitting there,
it's not progressing that much.
And then a new breath comes.
And so that's what happens next.
And especially if one
is speaking or singing,
then the exhaling is a much
longer and more continuous
process than the inhaling
which is very sudden.
So you talk and take a
breath, and you talk.
And so there's a lot more of
this going on than this, even
in normal speech and in normal
breathing to some extent
as well, but especially
when one is speaking.
And so an interesting
development
then is that if we have a
person who is speaking, then
we can generate what has
been called a puff train.
So we have here is the most
recent new breath getting
exhaled and then the
previous one was here, still
kind of floating around
and the one ahead
of that is dispersed a bit more.
But it hasn't progressed as far.
And so it's a
little bit thinner.
And if we kind of color
each breath a different way,
then what we're left
with is something
that actually looks an awful lot
like a continuous cone again.
So this is a puff train.
This could be, for example,
from speaking or singing.
And overall, the behavior
is quite similar to a jet
just where the K is replaced by
the time average momentum flux.
So I should mention that
this way of thinking here
was recently introduced
and verified experimentally
in a paper by Abkarian and
Howard Stone and collaborators,
and also introduced this
notion of the scaling
and showed that actually the
puff train has a scaling which
is very similar
to the initial jet
with the square root of time.
And so that's an important
concept come to now.
Because we want to ask
now, what if somebody
is speaking or even just
breathing continuously
in a certain direction and
generating aerosol particles,
how does their concentration
evolve in this sort
of a respiratory plume or jet.